so David today we're talking about first
Corinthians 7 where Paul deals with a
number of questions apparently that have
been proposed to him about marriage who
should get married and when and why and
whether it's okay he starts out though
on a really odd note he says now
concerning the matters about what you
wrote you just welled for a man not to
touch a woman where is this coming from
yes I assume that at this point he
begins to quote a letter that they had
given him he says considering the things
about which you wrote and and scholars
who our respective said that there's a
little clue in the rest of the letter
that whenever uses the little Greek
phrase parry duh which means now
concerning that he's bringing up a topic
that came to him in their letter and
therefore it seems to me quite likely
that one of the things they wrote to him
said dear Paul here's our thought it is
well for a man not to touch a woman what
do you think
and my supposition I want to have you
check me out on this but my supposition
on this is that in this strong sense
that Paul is shared with them that the
kingdom is beginning to break in upon
them and will reach its consummation
very soon that that they are to live as
faithful people and some of thought all
right what what would it mean to live is
a faithful person in the light of the
fact that the world is coming to an end
and we've already noticed that these
people are a little suspicious about the
physical about the sexual about the
embodiment of the human life so maybe
they're saying alright here's a plan in
order to be sure we're faithful at the
end of time why don't I say to my spies
why don't you and I just refrain from
sexual intercourse in the meantime
they'll Jesus comes again it is well for
a man not to touch a woman touch doesn't
mean touch it's clearly a sense that
this is an intercourse between the two
people and some of them are saying
here's a good plan but simply not have
intercourse because Jesus is coming
again soon and Paul disagrees with that
you know we talked about angels I think
in our last conversation and a little
later on in Christian history we have
the notion of the angelic life celibate
life and there may be hints of that
already here in the first century some
sort of well in Jesus own word that
angels neither marry nor are given in
marriage and if these are people who in
chapter 13 or
speaking in angelic tongues maybe
they're trying to lead angelic sexual
lives as well which is simply to refrain
from marriage with each other so this
would all fit with this notion of
spirituality that seems too deep a deep
spirituality that forgets how embodied
we still all are and need to be how
embodied we appropriately are it may be
something coming out of the the Greek
and Roman heritage of this deep
suspicion of the body at least yep that
there's some of its time but the soul
yeah some it strains the way that we
protect the soul is simply not to get
engaged with the impediments of the body
like sex mm-hmm and Paul smart about
this I think I'm I have never used this
at a wedding ceremony because I don't
think on the whole is understanding of
marriage is a little anti romantic or
pre romantic or non romantic but there's
some wisdom in all this partly he has an
extraordinarily practical word which is
the danger of that is if my spouse and I
say we're not going to have sex with
each other
then the temptation will be for one of
us loosening up on our marriage vows to
have sex with somebody else especially
if all things are lawful especially if
all things are lawful this could be
perfect permission for me to say all
right dear in relationship to you I'm
being extraordinarily chaste but then
there's the rest of the world out there
they're not good for marital relations
in that day any more than for this one
but there's also a deeper thing all the
way through which is his strong sense
that that given the fact that Christ is
coming again and that we live at the
dawning of a new age that all things
considered and the all things considered
is very important it is best for people
to remain as they are which is to say
widowers should stay unmarried if they
can widow should stay unmarried if they
can we'll come back to the odd word
about virgins and who they're supposed
to be married people should continue in
their marriage for the most part we'll
come back to that as well because what's
the point of making radical changes in
your life when you are living at the
dawn of a brand when the shape of this
world is passing away a brand new verse
31 what about the issue of divorce
that's something that Paul tackles and
that is for you and I want to I want
your help on contemporary applications
that this two interesting things about
that one is this is one of the few
places where he goes back to the words
of Jesus where he he's seen
you know the tradition that we get in
Mark and Matthew at least about the fact
that divorce people are not supposed to
remarry within the light of the
Christian Church and he holds that up as
a word of the Lord the major exception
he makes and and this includes people if
my spouse is a believer and I'm an
unbeliever that even that doesn't
necessarily give her permission to
divorce me unless I want to be divorced
that that on the whole and and I know
I'm running through too many things here
but so let me slow it down if if our
faith is embodied if my Christianity
let's say I'm the believer and she's the
unbeliever if my Christianity is
embodied then interestingly when we have
intercourse it's not that she profanes
me but that I may sanctify her that that
the me that I bring to her is the
sanctified me the saintly me and in that
sense our relationship to each other
however implicitly is also sanctifying
her that's a very powerful sense of the
importance of embodiment so so that even
in that case we shouldn't get divorced
the tricky place is where there's an
unbeliever who wants to divorce a
believer and at that point that seems to
be permitted which you've got some
thoughts about how that's worked out in
Catholic morality right this is a
so-called Pauline privilege
this is one of these cases where a
biblical injunction or admonition
becomes the basis for a legal tradition
okay
and in general divorce is prohibited by
the Catholic Church but there is one
exception and the exception is the one
embedded in Scripture right here that is
if two people are married and one is a
non believer and the non-believers to
separate the believer is free to remarry
it's not a question of annulment it's a
question of Paul's exception here
I think what's very interesting about
this is that Paul knows a tradition of
the sayings of Jesus and he knows this
is a command of Jesus and he's willing
to make an exception yeah yeah
so you're yes he's very Matic very
inflexible very pastoral yeah so yeah
there were certain firm lines that he's
willing to draw and certain yeah what in
traditions that he has from Jesus but
he's a little with a little wobble room
and and related to that just his strong
sense that that what like once again
what we do with our bodies is very
important for who we are and how
we relate to each other the the place
where it gets extremely unromantic is
that he says for those of us who are
widows or widowers that it's better not
to marry but if we if we simply the old
line is it's better to marry than burn
which I've often said was not the best
way to start a wedding homily now it's
dear sister and brother in Christ it's
better to marry than burn so let's go
ahead with these vows but it's his it's
his pragmatic alright if he had his
choice he'd have all widowers be
celibate as he is but the truth is some
people have a hard time with that so go
ahead and get married right now there's
another issue that he brings up here
under his general rubric of staying as
you are he introduces the issue of slave
yeah and it sort of pops up in the
middle of this it's not the main thing
we think he's saying of sexual and
marital issues but what do you make of
his his advice there in Chapter 7 verse
21 and following well as you point out
chapter 20 pointed out to me earlier
that chapter 21 is a little bit tricky
and let me just read to you the
different ways in oh yeah 7 chapter 7
verse 21 were you a slave when called do
not be concerned about it even if you
can gain your freedom and then one
translation says make use of your
present condition now more than ever
which makes it sound like I'm your slave
you offer me freedom and I say no no no
I'm gonna make use of my present
condition now more than ever which means
I'll stick around you be master I'll be
slave and I'll probably try to win you
to Christ buy my slave like docility
right that by the way would be in
conformity with the general advice he's
giving he very much stay as you are stay
as you are and it would also
interestingly enough mirror what goes on
in greco-roman philosophy where slavery
was viewed as indifferently as spiritual
interior yourself and very very much
founds the kind of stuff we find in
first Peter and some later Christian
writing where the assumption always is
slaves be obedient to your masters don't
stir it up don't mess it up the the
alternative translation of exactly the
same words is to would be this were you
a slave when called do not be concerned
about it even if you can gain your
freedom avail yourself now more than
ever which makes it sound like alright
if in this exceptional case the
presumably believing owner
to set you free then go for it listen
this is very tricky because one of the
things I always remember is Howard
Thurman who was a great african-american
religious thinker of the first part of
the middle of the 20th century writing
about his grandmother when teaching him
the Bible when they were growing up when
he was growing up and she loved to read
in the Gospels and she told him never to
read Paul because Paul was the one who
told all those masters that they should
own their slaves and that slave
shouldn't rebel and that's what had been
so much trouble for her people for all
those years so he could love the Bible
and he could love Jesus but he couldn't
love Paul and and we know from excellent
studies that slavery in that time was
not like slavery in the antebellum South
on the other hand for people whose
ancestors have been slaves and the
not-too-distant past it's very hard to
read these words and not in the
traditional reading and not find them
oppressive I think this is another one
of those cases where I think there's
probably a tradition that grows within
Christianity that's more adapted to the
general social norms of the correct
Roman world and that Paul was probably a
little more radical okay as he was also
on issues of women in leadership roles
and my hunch is that that alternative
reading that you've given us avail
yourself of the opportunity is what he
actually do interesting okay and why
because again it conforms to his
overarching concern to have the
principles embodied so I think he's
probably here resisting at the kind of
stoic a philosophical move saying
slavery isn't different it's the
internal civil freedom area no I think
he's saying here the body counts the
body count the kids the social condition
counts that's that's who you are
mmm wish he'd said it louder I wish I
want to circle back on the on the the
Roman Catholic business about the paul i
and privilege the and it's part of what
we were talking about on sexual ethics
before in in the protestant church the
difference i've seen in my own men ii is
that when i was a boy growing up in the
protestant parish with a Protestant
preacher father very much a mainline
church if a presbyterian or a
Piscopo lure an American Baptist or a
UCC pastor divorced that was it wasn't
it wasn't they were burned they weren't
banned but the minute the past work was
over that was no longer an option
because the very clear word from both
Paul and from Jesus was not divorce
except in the case of an unbeliever
being let go letting go an unbeliever
and that an unbeliever letting go of
believer that's the this was two
believers
divorcing and that was the end of the
password remarkable change at least in
the churches where I now serve where
numbers of people have divorced and
remarried and are able sometimes to keep
even the same parish where they were
before and along with that much more
freedom for laypeople not to get deeply
concerned with that and I don't know any
Protestant mainline Protestant pastor
who as a who has a rule there exception
who has a rule will never remarry
divorced people I don't know anybody who
does that and that's where the last 40
years or so but how do we how do we
interpret Paul for a world where I think
it's night I don't think we've even
bothered to figure out what the paul and
privilege is on this we've just said
that's not the way the world goes let's
move on well I think the one inspiration
I could take from Paul is what he does
with the command of Jesus okay that
there are teachings from which we can
learn that we have to adapt we have to
be able to apply them yeah that's very
powerful so that what I've used in here
is the distinction he makes between a
word from the Lord and his own opinions
the faithful person and that he's
willing to start with the word from the
Lord and then also say nonetheless as a
faithless not necessarily the final not
necessarily the final word flipping it
around I would say and I say this as one
who is frequently presided the marriage
ceremonies of people who have been
divorced I and the Christian Rite drives
me bonkers in a whole number of ways I
do think that the shift from I now take
you to be my spouse as long as we both
shall live - I take you to be my spouse
as long as we both feel like it it's not
necessarily good news for embodied
Christianity that part of what we see an
embodied Christianity is this sense that
of fidelity does matter and that
fidelity matters for the long term even
when it's hard I think Paul would agree
with I think Paul would agree with that